all right thanks everyone for tuning in
hope you had a great weekend I'm
broadcasting now from an undisclosed
location I traveled here over the
weekend with my family many hours in the
car many hours with three kids under six
and under in the car and you know I
remember when I was young and idealistic
and stupid well I'm still stupid but
they but the other two not so much back
before I had kids and I remember I used
to you know you'd you'd be driving on
the road and you'd be behind another car
a minivan or something and you could see
through their rearview their rear window
that they have one of those little TVs
there and the kids are watching a little
mermaid or whatever Disney thing and I
used to see that and I used to think to
myself man that's when I when I'm a
parent you know when I'm a parent I'm
not gonna put the TV on in the car for
the kids that says that's but I mean
like they don't get enough TV already
you know now you got to put TV on in the
car that's pathetic
no when I am a parent and I'm driving
with my kids I we will we'll talk and
we'll sing songs of gladness and we'll
just have a wonderful bonding time
that's what I thought before I was a
parent but now that I am I realize that
being stuck in a car for ten hours with
a bunch of little kids is is is actual
literal torture like if you if you were
to put a suspected terrorist in a
minivan with three kids for ten hours
that would violate the Geneva Convention
it's just it's inhumane treatment
because the thing with kids is they
don't ever stop talking or asking
questions or or whining I mean they're
just because they can't I guess when
they're in the car enclosed space they
can't move their bodies much they just
move their mouths even more to
compensate and after a while you just
can't take it anymore so we put the TV
on and that's how we made it through it
so all right on a more serious note a
couple things important things to talk
about today I want to talk about the
speaking of terrorists the domestic
terrorist organization and Tifa and the
chaos and violence this weekend that
that happened on the part of aunt Eva
Bob
we get to that a quick word from policy
genius you know part of adulthood is
having to do things that you don't
really want to do like well long car
rides with kids you know but another
part of adulthood is learning to
delegate the things you don't want to do
now I'd love to delegate driving my kids
right I'd love to maybe FedEx them ahead
of time to wherever we want to go and
we'll meet them there can't do that but
I can however delegate life insurance
shopping policy genius is the easy way
to shop for life insurance online in
just two minutes you can compare quotes
from top insurers to find your best
price once you apply the policy genius
team they'll handle all the paperwork
all the red tape all that stuff you
don't don't worry about that no sales
pressure no hidden fees just financial
protection and peace of mind so if you
need life insurance but you just don't
want to deal with all the legwork
that's where policy genius comes in head
to policy genius calm it's the easy way
to compare all the top insurers and find
the best value for you policy genius
delegate what you hate especially if you
hate getting life insurance
okay well the fascist hate group and
Tifa which ironically stands for anti
fascist which you know having a fascist
hate group that's anti it's a bit like
if the if coop if Ku Klux Klan's was
Latin for like racial tolerance that's
that's what it's that's what it's
similar to because of course they
anti-fascist but but that's the exact
opposite of what they really are they're
also domestic terror group and they held
what is being called a quote protest
over the weekend in Portland but this
protest was nothing more than a violent
riot which is what all of their protests
are like in fact their left wingers in
general have a suspicious habit of
having protests that really turn into an
excuse to beat the hell out of people
and set things on fire think back to
back to when BLM was staging these
quote-unquote protests all across the
country but really you had entire city
blocks that were on fire and people were
throwing bricks and looting that's the
way left-wing protests go especially
with an Tifa so this was a violent riot
riot
that was organized and planned planned
and organized by a group that exists for
no other reason than to plan and
organize violent riots but this is worse
than what we've seen before this somehow
fell below an tifa's already
subterraneous standards now the Portland
antifa especially has been particularly
bad for a long time especially bad
mostly because the Portland Police are
non-existent
it seems we're left wingers are
concerned anyway and Tifa in Portland
they've had the run of the town for a
while
they're allowed to shut down city blocks
assault people at will
and the police just stand by and watch
they don't do anything so as an example
before we get to what happened this
weekend as a just a primer to kind of
get you warmed up here they are a few
months ago shutting down a block
directing traffic
and then someone disobeyed their traffic
signals so they chased that guy down
with a baseball bat watch this
[Music]
[Applause]
okay but but but that was a few months
ago right as I said let's look at what
happened this weekend conservative
journalist and II know who apparently
lives in Portland showed up to cover the
demonstration slash quote-unquote
protest and he wound up being viciously
assaulted by these thugs the I'll show
you one of the videos and by the way I
should just a disclaimer all of the
videos I'm gonna show in the show today
are all upsetting and violent and
there's blood and stuff so you know if
you have kids that you're watching this
with and they don't want to you don't
want them to see it then that's a fair
warning but it's important though that
those of us who are old enough to see it
do see it so that we know what's going
on out there
so this is the first this only shows
part of the beating watch watch this
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
okay he was the main thing you see there
and and you gotta be careful here
because you saw at the very beginning of
that cut how he was punched he was
assaulted he was punched in the face by
someone who ran up very courageously ran
up sucker-punched him then ran away and
then you see him being sprayed with all
kinds of various substances what you're
seeing of the media and we'll talk about
this in a minute but the media has
mostly ignored this when they do show a
clip what they'll do is they'll show if
they're gonna show any of this which
most of them don't but if they're gonna
show it they'll still cut out the part
at the very beginning where he got hit
and they'll show only the part where
he's being sprayed with what looks like
silly string now they also were throwing
milkshakes milkshakes at him because
this is the left-wing thing now of
throwing milkshakes at people milk
shaking they call it but these milk
which is already assault to throw
something at somebody is assault period
even if it's a milkshake
these milkshakes though the police
reported were some of them were laced
with cement mix okay so these were not
just regular old milkshakes anyway
here's know after the beating I just got
beat up by the crowd no police at all
in the middle of the street and they
stole my GoPro and he punched me several
times in my face and my head I'm
bleeding
whether how well of you yeah where the
hell were you know your name my name's
Andy no you know where I had been
assaulted twice earlier today and
reported it to your Pugliese hey nothing
was done I was in the street in the
front documenting this I'd like to help
you can you tell me
they stole my evidence they stole my
GoPro and then he proceeds to talk to
the police and he's trying to he's
asking them good question where were you
but he talks to them and that's what the
rest of that video is this was not some
little scuffle no was admitted to a
hospital overnight reportedly with a
brain bleed he was seriously hurt he
could have been could have been killed
if you know if your brain is bleeding
that's I mean you that's that's a
potentially fatal situation it's not an
exaggeration to say that antifa the
antifa Punk's were trying to kill people
now one of the dumbest defenses of aunty
Fay that I've seen this weekend and all
of the defenses are to defend them at
all is dumb so there's no smart defence
one of the dumbest of all the dumb ones
is I've some people have said well you
know they they're not they haven't
killed anybody okay they're not like
those neo-nazis have killed somebody
okay it's not for lack of trying though
they it does appear that they are trying
to kill people or at the very least
they're assaulting people without any
regard for whether or not they happen to
kill the person I'll show you what I
mean here are the antifa terrorists
using what looks like a crowbar or a
metal bar of some kind against an older
man and then someone else steps in
heroically to protect the man and then
they start hitting him as well with the
metal bar watch watch watch this one
[Applause]
[Music]
okay that's to smack somebody in the
head with a metal bar crowbar baseball
bat whatever it is that is attempted
murder you're trying to kill them you
could very easily kill them here's a
Michelle Malkin has was compiling
pictures of the aftermath so here's a
picture she had of the of the hero who
stepped in is that the S at the hospital
look at the gashes on his head look at
these pictures here
okay that's someone who you know that's
someone who was in a life who was put in
a life-threatening situation when you
end up with gashes like that on your
head and then here's the older man
another picture the older man covered in
blood all right
despite how it's being portrayed in some
corners this was not just a bunch of
dorks throwing milkshakes this was
something more serious than that
although they are a bunch of dorks let's
be clear about that
they're dangerous terrorists yes and we
can't minimize the threat that they pose
but individually they're also a bunch of
effeminate weaklings and dorks who would
never dare go one-on-one against any of
the I mean you saw the guy with the
gashes in the head who they they you
think any of those people would go
one-on-one against him you think any of
those you think any of those weaklings
those antifoam weaklings would dare take
off their mask and walk up to that guy
and punch them square in the face and
then stay there just to get the response
you think they dare have a fair fight
with anybody no it's it's really easy to
put up put on a mask if you have no
moral standards and you're a coward then
it's really easy to put on a mask and
run up among a group of people smack
someone in the head with a metal bar and
then run away
that's anyone could you know a
six-year-old could do that anyone could
do that so these are these are weak
pathetic despicable effeminate cowards
all of them and I just
I want to emphasize that because it
maybe it's not the most important thing
in the world but when I hear people say
domestic terrorists and it and all of
that is true but it just you you you we
also don't want to make them sound you
know you unfortunately in our society
these days when you start describing
people that way you you you run the risk
of making them sound cool or something
in the in the in the ears and in the
minds of very stupid people who think
about other wearing masks and they're
out there fighting oh that must be cool
no it's not because it's violent and
they're hurting people and it could
possibly kill someone and also again
these are just the biggest losers on
earth all of them this is what an Tifa
does this is their whole thing their
only tactic violence and intimidation
we've seen it not just in Portland but
in many states any time an t4 ghen
eise's anytime they get together this is
what happens it's a domestic terrorist
organization and that's how it should be
treated everybody associated with anty
anty fuscia rested anyone who is a known
member or associate participant with an
Tifa should be arrested this group
should be outlawed it should be banned
because we have the right to peaceably
assemble in this country but when you're
we do not have the right to assemble for
but for violent riots we don't have the
right to assemble for the sole purpose
of hurting and intimidating people and
that's what an Tifa does they are a
terrorist organization and that's what
needs to happen legally although at this
point I would say you know before we
even get to well direct domestic
terrorist organization rounding up the
leaders throwing them in jail
and I think that's all gonna be I I
think that all that should happen your
police raids and everything Rud I mean
show up in force fighting these people
in their moms basements frog-marched
them out and throw them in prison and
see how they like it they're in prison
with the other inmates but
and by the way you you know you antifa
they pretend that they're fighting
against neo-nazis which which they
aren't okay there weren't any as far as
I'm aware well certainly in those videos
the people being at and II know is not a
neo-nazi the people that they're
assaulting are not neo-nazis so they
pretend they're fighting against
neo-nazis for the most part they're not
they're just assaulting random people
and anyone who happens to disagree with
them but hey if you really want to if
you really want to go up again if you if
you really want to fight neo-nazis well
they have neo-nazis in prison and those
are real neo-nazis and so yeah why don't
you go let's throw these guys in prison
and let them let them tangle with the
neo-nazis in there and see how it goes
where they can't put on a mask and they
don't have a group and you know they're
probably not gonna have a weapon I guess
they could try to get a shiv in the
prison yard somewhere but yeah let's see
how these tough guys like it when
they're when they're we throw them in
prison in there with real neo-nazis but
anyway that's the legal part of this the
other part of his is personal on a
personal level if if you are being
swarmed by a violent mob if people are
using mace and metal bars and crowbars
and throwing bricks at you or whatever
else you have every right legal and
moral to defend yourself using whatever
means you deem necessary if you're being
assaulted with a metal bar that is
assault with a deadly weapon
you could die you this is someone who is
trying to kill you and now you have the
legal and moral right to respond with
the force that equals the force being
used against you that's you're not a
blah
to be a victim you don't have to stand
there and take it one of these days
these gutless Punk's are going to try
this garbage on a fan of the Second
Amendment and things are gonna go badly
for the gutless Punk in that case that's
gonna happen and one of you it's gonna
happen it's gonna happen soon
you just they've been doing this for
months now years eventually they're
gonna target the wrong person and when
that happens you know that's when the
media is gonna take note and we're gonna
try to make us feel sorry for whatever
and Tifa Punk gets that response and
there's well you know this is terrible
know when that happens whose fault is it
gonna be not the guy who defends himself
I'll tell you that why don't you go down
here's a thought aunt Eva why don't you
go down to Texas and try this try
shutting down streets and assaulting
random passers-by in Texas and see what
happens now I don't wish death or harm
on anyone and I don't like to see this
chaos and violence I wish it wasn't
happening but I do want people to
protect themselves and I do think here's
the thing
the ante funks they should be afraid to
do this kind of thing now I don't think
anyone should just live in fear in
general and nobody should be afraid in
America to express their point of view
to exercise their legitimate First
Amendment rights but you should be
afraid to assault random people you
should be afraid to run around with a
mask and a crowbar hitting people you
should be afraid to do just like you
should be afraid to break into
somebody's house it's a sign of a
healthy country of a healthy
civilization when Pete
are afraid tack that way because they
know that there are going to be
consequences they're going to be legal
consequences and there may be even more
serious and immediate consequences than
that because the law is not the law is
not going to sit there and let you do it
and the person you're attacking isn't
going to just sit there and let you do
it
that's a sign of a healthy civilization
it's a sign of an unhealthy civilization
when people feel they can do this with
impunity and they're not afraid and they
feel perfectly safe and secure these
auntie fogs walking around in masks just
you know just with their with the
crowbar slung over their shoulders just
strolling randomly proudly around that's
the sign of an unhealthy situation in a
society yeah that's the things that an
Tifa it they seem to want a civil war
but they're gonna be marching to war
with milkshakes and metal bars the other
side has most of the guns they they want
to escalate this they want violence I
don't they do but it they haven't quite
figured out you know that the the other
side that that's where almost all the
NRA members are this fans the Second
Amendment people who not only own guns
but know how to use them are very
proficient in them that's where most of
the you know the other side's where most
of those people are and if an Tifa
continues escalating I think eventually
they're gonna learn that lesson the hard
way I hope it doesn't come to that but
if they continue is it can't go on like
this indefinitely but what's in some
ways even more disturbing more
concerning more frightening than an
tifa's behavior is the reaction from the
left or lack thereof as of this morning
not at as of this morning anyway not a
single and this is enough because it's
been two to three days as of this
morning not a single Democratic
presidential candidate had uttered a
word of combat condemnation against an
Tifa or the assaults this weekend
I mean these people were bludgeoning
people using pepper spray attacking
journalists and the Democrat candidates
can't even bring themselves to condemn
it that's incredible and very it's a
real scary situation because why aren't
they condemned in it because they know
that there are a lot of anti feh and
people and a lot of an tithi
sympathizers in their base okay they've
done the research they've done the
polling internally they know they know
that it would be politically disastrous
for them with their base to come out and
say hey ante for shouldn't be beating
people with metal bars what does that
tell you about the left that Democratic
pleas aren't just fringe being Democrat
presidential candidates feel like they
can because they're cowards and
opportunists they feel like they can't
come out and condemn this because
they're gonna upset their base it's it's
not like that on the other side I gotta
tell you because you could do the what
about ISM of neo-nazis and all that all
you want yeah conservatives come out in
condemn neo-nazis it's not a Republican
politicians they have no hesitation
there's no hesitation it's what we're
not yeah sure I'll condemn neo-nazis all
day there's that guy that ran the girl
over he's in jail you know I came out I
said that they should put the guy in
front of a firing squad and I think they
should
I've got yet a murderous neo-nazi yeah
go out and execute him put him down like
a dog absolutely that's I have no
compunction about that at all
so on the right there really isn't much
of a hesitate now I I take issue with
the whole idea that neo-nazis are
right-wing in the first place but even
if I said okay they are they're the
extremist element of the right-wing even
if I agreed with that well whatever it's
we have no that does not make me
hesitate
oh well should I I don't know would it
be day would it be would it be a risky
for me to condemn them of course I
condemn them that's not what you find on
the left
they are very hesitant to condemn the
violent extremists on their side of the
fence likewise the media
has been very very reserved in its
coverage and condemnation even though
again it a journalist was attacked a
journalist was put in the hospital the
bleeding brain yet the media treated
this as a non-event basically to give
you an idea of of just how trivialized
this event has been with the media CNN's
brian Stelter who's a guy on CNN who
specializes in covering attacks on the
media that's what he talks about all the
time he Trump's sends out a mean tweet
about the media this guy Stella Stelter
Stelzer or whatever how you pronounce it
Brian good old Brian he'll spend a whole
show talking about the means we okay now
he's getting credit for being one of the
guys in the media one of the only ones
in the media to actually cover these
attacks and condemn them and I'm going
to show you what he said how he handled
it and remember this is probably the
most passionate condemnation offered by
anyone in the left-wing media is this
watch this one more important story that
you need to know about before take a
break this is a protest that turned
violent against a member of the media in
Portland Oregon this weekend
conservative journalist Andy note was
out there covering rival protests on
Saturday and tief on one side right-wing
figures on the other side but as the
demonstrations classed protesters it
appears to be antifa protesters then
attacked know he's been out there in the
past he's been covering protests in
Portland for quite some time his critics
say he's there to cause trouble but
that's unacceptable the idea that he
would be attacked that he would be
bloodied in that way unacceptable
period and it's important that every
make that clear even left-wing critics
who don't like him and things like that
okay maybe you'll tell me that beggars
can't be choosers but that is weak that
is very weak he mentions it right before
a break is oh by the way before we go to
break he spends 20 seconds on it he
calls it unacceptable sending someone to
that yes it is it is unacceptable but
that's the that's the harshest words you
could come up with is unacceptable you
know beating someone in the in the skull
with a with a bat until their brain is
bleed on except that is unacceptable
no unacceptable behavior
is I mean that's what I said to my my
daughter this morning because she pulled
her brother's hair I said that's not
acceptable
that's unacceptable the two kids picking
on each other this is a lot more than
unacceptable you know that that Charles
Manson that so it's pretty unacceptable
yes it was pretty tacky unacceptable
behavior I got to tell you murdering
people I mean pretty yeah you know not a
fan that's just it's the week but that's
that's the best the media could do is
that and just so you're not you don't
make the mistake of being impressed and
say well at least he said something
the only reason Brian said anything is
because he knew he knew he had to say
something I mean this is what he does he
talks about attacks on the media and
you've got a journalist being sent to
the hospital everyone's talking about on
social media he knew he couldn't ignore
it that was ignoring it was not an
option he couldn't do that and so he did
bare baby you can't even call it bare
minimum was so better he'd say he spent
20 seconds just so he could say that he
talked about it and just so that a week
from now two weeks from now a month from
now when someone calls him to account
and says hey you know just so that next
time Trump says sends a mean tweet or
mean gift about the media and brian
Stelter spends a whole show spends five
shows talking about it and someone says
hey you know you're talking about this
you didn't say anything about wouldn't
when the conservative journalist was
attacked that he could come back and say
oh yeah well look at this that's the
only reason he did that little small
tiny twenty second segment was was just
to give him that moment a month from now
when someone on Twitter tries to call
him to the task and he can retweet his
little segment and said he can he can
really own them right own the
conservatives with that with that
devastating comeback that's the only
reason he did that remember cNN has
openly defended antifa in the past this
is this was last year Don Lemon this is
what he had to say about a TiVo it says
it right in the name antifa anti-fascism
which is what they were there
fighting listen there's you know no
organization is perfect there are some
violence no one condones of violence but
there were different reasons for antifa
and for these neo-nazis to be there one
racist fascists the other group fighting
racist fashions there is it fascist
there's a distinction there
okay Trump has obviously gotten a lot of
grief for his infamous there were fine
people on both sides coming this is like
that this is well no organization is
perfect but at least they're fighting
fascists so that's how CNN feels about
it even they're fully in support I want
you to imagine something for a minute
and then we're gonna move on here in a
moment but imagine the response if a
swarm of Trump supporters in Maggi hats
assaulted a CNN reporter and put him in
the hospital with a brain injury imagine
how the media would be reacting today
imagine the fiery statements from all
the Democratic candidates imagine just
imagine imagine it think about how they
how they reacted when some Catholic
school kids smiled at a Native American
guy that was a week-long news cycle all
they did was smile at a guy they didn't
even lay hands on him
think about how they reacted with
justice Millette okay the media as a
headline news the Democrat Camilla
Harris and Cory Booker they jumped on it
immediately when justice Millette
pretended that he was assaulted by two
mega hat guys so that's how they go with
that stuff but with this crickets and
that's not even the worst of it okay I
mean I said I was gonna move on but I
can't it's like it just keeps getting
worse all you have to do is go on social
media go on Twitter you'll find legions
of leftist many of them prominent with
with large followings verified Twitter
users and all that actually defending an
Tifa hey outright defending them
encouraging more violence here's a
verified Twitter user Sara gaily thirty
thousand followers he or she is in a
tweet that I think has since been
deleted calling for her political
opponents to be bludgeoned with bricks
look at this tweet here
she's not suspended from Twitter for
that by the way and there's a whole more
a lot more of that on Twitter the
attitude of the left is clear if you
disagree with us you don't have the
right to be safe or secure if you
disagree with us you all bets are off
that's how the left is approaching all
right what else
well there was look at the emails in a
second but first there was well I guess
I have to mention this there was a there
was it's hard to keep track because all
the left does anymore is just
demonstrate so there was a there was
another left-wing demonstration this
weekend this one in New York and this
one wasn't violent
okay so I'll give him that it was an
anti pride event okay an anti pride of
it but I said it's a leftist anti-bride
so this was not an anti gay pride event
by advocates of traditional marriage
know these were gay activists protesting
Gay Pride and the reason why they
protested because I could think of read
I could think of plenty of good reasons
for even gay activists to be opposed to
you know these gay pride events but it's
not for any of those reasonable reasons
here's here's why here's a video from
The Daily Beast explaining what this
anti pride event was all about I think
the importance is a lot of people forget
that pride is supposed to be a
celebration so didn't start on a happy
note just started off a lots of protests
and rally at birth
and blood and sweat and tears so
remembering where it started and
appreciating that is so
[Applause]
you don't need police to be safe unique
community to be safe we need communities
to feel safe and back for some of us
police mean the opposite of safety it
means violence and that's what the first
Stonewall riot was about okay did you
get that they're protesting the fact
that police and corporations are
supporting gay pride that's what they're
protest so they were approached they
were oppressed when government and
corporations were not supportive of
their cause they were oppressed by that
and now the government and corporations
are supportive they're still oppressed
they're oppressed by everyone's they're
oppressed either way so they were
oppressed when they weren't accepted
they're oppressed now that they are
accepted and it's not even like very
oppressed even though they're being
accepted now it's now they're being
oppressed by the acceptance of people
it's it's it's amazing it's amazing how
determined the left is to be victims no
matter what and they and they will
anything and victimizes them not to keep
comparing you know bringing it in
comparisons with my children because my
children are so much better than
left-wing activists but and my children
will never be left-wing activists so
help me God but anyway this it reminds
me of like my my my two and a half year
old we're in the when we were driving in
the car for that ten hour journey yeah
he would start crying for a toy and then
I would reach back and I give him a toy
and but then then he's crying because
it's the wrong two when he throws the
toy he starts crying again it's like
you're trying to appease him but he's
two-and-a-half no matter what you do if
one yeah with two and a half year olds
when they get into a funk when they get
into a mood no matter what you do is
gonna it will be a cause to make them
cry no matter what it is with the
exception maybe of did either giving
them ice cream that's maybe the one
thing that they that no two and a half
year old would cry about other than that
they'll cry about anything and but
that's okay for a two and a half year
old it's unfortunate when you see
left-wing and activists who are adults
acting the same way no matter what you
do it is a reason for them to cry and so
now they're crying that they're being
accepted
oh poor us we're being accepted and
loved by everyone everyone loves us and
wants to express their support oh my
gosh alright let's move on to emails
quickly Matt Walsh show at gmail.com
Matt Walsh Oh gmail.com this is from
Diane says hi Matt at listen to you
every day you mentioned a cologne you
were wearing from a sponsor wearing a
man at the store said it smells like
America it's a true story by the way
totally true I would never make up a
story for the sake of Hawking a product
you know that is beneath me
I told my friend and he wants to smell
like America - what was that cologne
plus we want to support you this was
maybe two weeks ago that story made me
laugh out loud thanks for your time
that was a cologne made by the fine
folks over a Duke Canon so go check out
Duke cannon they've got a lot of great
products I have I have many of the
products myself so Duke cannon is what
it is all right this from David says
greetings Lord Walsh ruler of all things
past president things yet to come your
semi omniscient rule will be challenged
by none and your sudden and inevitable
rise to power might now see this is how
you address me okay this is this is
polite my humble name is David revealer
of heresies I do not wish to call you
semi omniscient however it has come to
my attention oh yeah he said semi
omniscient before I didn't even notice
that I guess kind of proving the point
isn't it however it has come to my
attention that you have not properly
threatened Russia for their past
opposition to your present and future
bearded dictatorship this horrifying a
grotesque monstrosity of a law in the
18th century required a beard tax to be
enforced on citizen what is truly
horrifying however is the punishment of
the offenders who did not pay the beard
texts the police shaved the offender's
beard I apologize for bringing such
hideous information into your glorious
bearded presence however I believe that
any information regarding heresies as
awful as this would give you all the
more reason to destroy Russia in a
righteous fury in your eyes
global domination the only request I
have for this piece of information is
that you keep me around as long as you
see fit to reveal more heresies such as
this and then when the time comes to an
end I would request a swift and painless
death long live the beard well I was not
aware of that but how dare you assume
that I wasn't aware of something first
of all second how dare you traumatize me
with this historical information if
we've learned anything over the past few
years it's that history can be very
traumatizing to people in the present
and so the best thing we can do is
ignore it pretend it didn't happen
and that's what you should have done
here that was your fatal mistake but
you're literally fatal mistake David so
I cannot make the promise that you asked
me to make as far as destroying Russia
for for their for their historical sins
of the beard tax I'll have to look into
it well yeah absolutely will destroy it
but but but then again you know as part
of my dictatorship we're going to I will
be destroying you know all of the
countries in the world except for this
one and then ultimately everybody in
this country except for me so you know
Russia is just it's kind of gonna happen
anyway but I guess they'll move to the
front of the line alright this is a
finally from Dustin says hey Matt I
think I know the underlying reason for
the selfishness in our current dating /
relationship culture as exemplified in
the Cosmo article you read on Friday
nihilism the philosophical underpinning
of so many people's lives
usually unconsciously held like an
iceberg whose masts mostly lies hidden
underneath is as follows while there is
no God no afterlife no ultimate meaning
or purpose in life as louis c.k put it
underneath everything in your life
here's that thing that empty that
forever empty the knowledge that it's
all for nothing and you're alone Louie
CK say that that's um that's pretty grim
but but true from actually a beautiful
way of putting the Nile the nihilistic
point of view number two if this life is
all I have I better get all the
happiness I can now number three sexual
pleasure / expression fulfillment is the
highest form of happiness number four
therefore I can do whatever makes me
happy sexually and you're a monster if
you say otherwise
as you can see this assumption also
underpins the whole modern religion of
sexuality ISM as well what are your
thoughts keep up the good work well you
know I'm not gonna not gonna not gonna
add my thoughts much to it because I
think that you I agree totally and I
think that you put it put it very well
that is that's what it comes down this
what we're talking about if I can even
remember all the way back on Friday yeah
we read an article from Cosmo which of
course I have a subscription to Cosmo so
I read you know I read their articles
every month but the article was someone
a woman bragging about all the men that
she's cheated on and saying she doesn't
feel sorry about it and you know she'll
do it again she feels like she wants to
and that is an extreme manifestation of
this very common what you're talking
about here the nihilism nihilism which I
guess which is at the root of everything
which is to say they're at the root is
nothing you know it's like roots of a
tree that go all the way down to just a
hole a cavity where there's nothing
really there so the roots themselves are
not really rooted in anything but
because of that as you point out you
have no fundamental purpose in life and
so you have to make up your own purpose
and so your purpose is your own sexual
fulfillment just feeling good and then
if that's the purpose your purpose of
life then sure you could cheat you could
do whatever you want to relate to it
because it's really all about you it's
about making you feel good and I think
one thing that that so there's that's
obviously a selfish and bad and sinful
and wrong way of approaching life it's
also just so it just lacks creativity
yeah that's the other thing about the
nihilists and hedonist they have no
creativity so you you you think there's
no fundamental purpose of life which is
horrible so you're gonna make up your
own purpose and that's the best you can
come up with is your whole purpose is
just to have sex and feel good I mean
it's like have some creativity for
goodness sakes if you're gonna be a
nihilist and make up your own purpose of
life which I don't recommend at least be
unique like think of something else
that's my thing I mean maybe you know
just be creative maybe maybe your
purpose in life is is I don't know I
can't even think of an example right now
because I don't have the creativity
anyway either but at the same time I'm
not a nihilist so I don't have to make
up my own purpose all right we'll we'll
leave it there thanks everybody for
watching thanks for listening Godspeed
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin back
from vacation with the Andrew Clavin
show and I have to congratulate the left
they have invented a terrific system to
rationalize their own wickedness by
defining the opposition of evil they
license their own evil they call us
hateful while they cease with hate they
call us violent while they assault us
and scream at us and spit on us to call
us racist while they see everything in
terms of race they call us fascist while
they try to undermine every freedom our
founding defends that clearer we are
about what we're fighting for the easier
it'll be to beat them we'll talk about
that on the Andrew Clavin show I'm
Andrew Clavin